en tout cas oui c'est important pour les
ukrainiens ça faisait partie
effectivement de leur demande quand il
disait aux occidentaux de de faire plus
de mettre davantage la pression sur
moscou clairement le fait de d'exclure
la russie donc de cette plateforme
interbancaire swift est très bien
accueillie d'ailleurs plusieurs
responsables ukrainiens lors l'on écrit
sur twitter qu'il s'agisse du premier
ministre ou du ministre des affaires
étrangères donc oui c'est une bonne
nouvelle après il faudra voir dans le
détail quand même
quelle banque sont exclues parce qu'en
fait c'est pas tout ça c'était la banque
voilà c'est pas toutes les banques
russes qui sont exclues de swift c'est
certaines certaines banques y reste
visiblement sur l'insistance de certains
pays comme l'allemagne ou comme l'italie
qui évidemment je souhaite pouvoir
continuer à commercer et à payer
évidemment ce qu'ils doivent à la russie
concernant notamment l'approvisionnement
en énergie en pétrole et en gaz donc
voilà il faudra voir dans le détail
quelle est l'efficacité de cette mesure
qui n'est quand même pas à 100% il a
fallu faire un compromis au sein même
des pays européens pour parvenir à cette
décision mouvement sur le front
économique mouvement aussi